The expression "like talking to a wall"...
...means that the person you're talking to can't or won't listen.
Because walls can't listen. Or can they?
It's exactly this kind of accepted wisdom that we love debunking.
If you have ingenuity and determination, then really, nothing's impossible.
We're going to attach an accelerometer to one side of the wall.
If we're right, it should be sensitive enough to detect...
...the tiny vibrations produced by a person talking on the other side.
We'll be filtering the signal...
...and then playing it through speakers to a group of kids on the far side.
So, in a way, the kids will be listening to what the wall is hearing.
We won't have someone just talking to a wall.
He'll be reading a whole storybook.
Let's see if it works.
There was one difference, although very slight.
...forever in peace just as they ought to.